[Musique]
au delà des pyramides au delà de ce que
vous pensez savoir découvrez l'egypte
inconnu je continue à ne pas y croire
ce qui arrive ensuite est un grand
moment d'archéologie moderne un grand
pharaon accueillent ces enfants dans le
monde des ténèbres
je n'ai jamais rien vu de tel en magie
la découverte d'un tombeaux datant de
plusieurs millénaires
rien de tel n'a jamais été trouvé
auparavant
peter vouloir de vous guident au travers
de cette découverte
dans le prochain épisode de l'egypte au
delà des pires années 800 km au sud du
caire un temple d'une beauté
époustouflante et perchée à la limite du
vaste désert
[Musique]
à l'intérieur de ces murs se trouve la
représentation effondré faisant un
millier de tonnes de l'un des plus grand
roi d'égypte qui a laissé derrière lui
l'un des grands mystères égyptien le
sort de ses nombreux enfants
il s'agit d'une saga dont certains
pensent qu'elle s'achèvera dans un
tombeau se trouvant dans la légendaire
et reculées fallait des rois
[Musique]
cet enchevêtrement de pierre énorme
constitué autrefois une statue de ramsès
deux souverains d'égypte près de 1200
ans avant l'ère chrétienne
son visage contempler le ciel voici une
épaule c'était l'une des plus imposantes
statues jamais sculpté et elle avaient
été érigées ici dans leur âme et ses
hommes le temple mortuaire de ramsès
près de la ville que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui sous le nom de louxor on
pense que ce sont les chrétiens coptes
qui ont renversé la statue au courant du
vème siècle après jésus-christ au fil
des siècles des tremblements de terre
ont contribué à détruire plus avant le
portrait écroulé du pharaon
bien entendu ramsès a eu le dernier mot
aujourd'hui sur l'image n'est
certainement pas celle d'une heure wind
colossal
[Musique]
cette statue symbolise mieux le rôle de
ramsès ii dans l'histoire égyptienne
c'est un roi qui conduit ses armes et à
la victoire qui a fait construire les
plus incroyables structure à travers
l'egypte son règne a duré soixante sept
ans c'est le deuxième plus long règne
d'entre tous les pharaons et quand il
meurt l'histoire se souvient de lui
comme ramsès legrand
[Musique]
lorsqu'il succède à son père s'était
premier en 1280 avant jésus-christ
ramsès n'a pas beaucoup plus de 20 ans
seti a été un pharaon dynamique qui a
veillé à ce que son fils soit bien
préparée pour lui succéder dans son
enfance le jeune ramsey sa compagne son
père à la guerre il apprend de première
main a commandé une armée encore jeune
homme il apprend les techniques
d'ingénierie
il supervise les carrières de pierre
d'où sont extraits les obélisques qui
vont décorer les temples égyptiens la
préparation porte ses fruits
la stabilité et les accomplissements du
règne de ramsès ii en tant que pharaons
sont inégalées
l'adolescent qui suivait son père dans
la bataille devient un guerrier
déterminer qui défend l'egypte contre
les menaces extérieures
ramsès a également fait ses classes
comme ingénieur il lègue à l'histoire
certaines des structures égyptienne les
plus belles et les plus monumentales
dans une civilisation de grand bâtisseur
ce pharaon fait sans doute partie des
plus grands plus de 3000 citoyens
égyptiens sont employés rien que pour
tailler la pierre pour le temple
magnifique qu'il se dédie à lui-même
leur âme et ses hommes
[Musique]
et dans les falaises imposante qui
surplombe le nil nubien ramsay
s'aggraver l'un des plus grands
monuments dédiés à l'ego le temple
d'abou simbel à la beauté saisissante
quatre statues colossales du pharaon
lui-même se dresse haute de 20 mètres
[Musique]
eh bien je pense que en fait ramsès
s'inscrit parmi les grandes figures de
l'histoire de l'égypte ancienne
ce n'est pas le plus grand roi
certainement mais c'est l'un des grands
rois de l'egypte ancienne
il a bien marqué son époque d'abord par
un règne lot 67 embraye picard est
considérable dans l'histoire de l'egypte
ancienne
ramsès est effectivement un grand
guerrier et c est dans le projet de
construction ont inspiré un respect mêlé
de crainte de la part des gens à
commencer par les premiers touristes
descendent dans le nil
durant les périodes grecque et romaine
au cours de son règne la renommée et la
richesse de l'egypte s'accroissent et
ses sujets connaissent une période
d'abondance et de sécurité
ramsès à une opinion tellement bonne de
ses propres accomplissements qu'il va
prendre la mesure présomptueuse de se
déclarer divin un dieu vivant parmi les
mortels
cependant ce statut divin n'impressionne
pas un groupe fameux de visiteurs dans
ce pays
la tradition judéo-chrétienne nomme
ramsès deux pharaons au moment où moïse
men l'exode des israélites hors d'égypte
certains des plus grands
accomplissements de ramsès sont
peut-être ses prodigieuses prouesses
dans le domaine de la paternité label
néfertari et son épouse la plus connue
cependant il a de nombreuses autres
reines officielle des épouses
secondaires et des concubines avec
toutes ces femmes
ramsès engendrent plus d'une centaine
d'enfants qu'on lui connaît dont au
moins 50 fils il n'est sans doute pas
inhabituel pour un pharaon d'avoir de
nombreuses épouses et de nombreux
enfants ce qui est inhabituel en
revanche et le fait que ramsès face
inscrire la liste et sculpter les
portraits de ses enfants
sur les murs des structures qu'il bâtit
les enfants de ramsès la représentation
des enfants de ramsès dans la plupart de
ces temples apparaissent comme une
originalité il est vrai il faut quand
même savoir que déjà à l'époque
d'aménophis 4mm aménophis iii un peu
inférieur mans la présence des enfants
dans le contexte des scènes religieuses
liturgique était déjà très présents pour
la plupart des pharaons de l'egypte
ancienne
nous n'avons aucun renseignement
concernant les membres de la famille
royale
en ce qui concerne ramsès ii on connaît
les noms d'un grand nombre de ses
épouses ainsi que ceux de beaucoup de
ses fils et filles plus de deux
douzaines dans chaque cas ramsès ii est
effectivement un personnage singulier
ans ce qu'aucun pharaons que ce soit
avant lui ou après lui n'a jamais
accordé autant d'attention à ses enfants
en dépit de leur reconnaissance publique
si inhabituelle de la part de leur père
on ne sait pas grand chose de la vie de
tous ses enfants être héritier du trône
de ramsès est un processus frustrant il
règne pendant 67 ans et survit à 5 de
ses successeurs
[Musique]
le premier de ces successeur s'appelle
amont rpp chef et il meurt dans le
courant de la quarantième année du règne
de ramsès si ramsay s'est effectivement
le pharaon de l'exode
alors à mon mbp chef devait être le
premier des garçons à mourir lorsque
dieu condamne l'egypte à subir les sept
plaies mais on doute que l'histoire soit
jamais capable de confirmer cela d
autres pinces de ramsès on ne connaît
que peu de détails
le fils numéro 4 témoin cette est tenu
en très haute estime et se peut qu'il
était le favori de son père c'est un
prêtre important et il supervise la
réalisation d'un grand nombre des
projets de construction des plus fameux
de son père il décède dans la 55e année
du règne de ramsès mérenptah est le
troisième fils de ramsès dont on ne sait
pas grand chose avant qu'il soit désigné
général de l'armée dans la quarantième
année du règne de ramsès il est sans
doute le véritable pouvoir derrière le
trône pendant la dernière décennie de la
vie de son père même endroit
vieillissant ramsès et grands pour un
égyptien
environ 1 m 75 dans ces dernières années
il souffre d'arthrite et d'une déviation
de la colonne vertébrale et comme tous
ses concitoyens il a des problèmes
dentaires il est de constitution mince
avec un des traits crochus et de grandes
oreilles percées
on pourrait penser qu'il est un peu
vaniteux car même dans ses vieux jours
ses cheveux sont un d'une couleur rouge
du payante
jusqu'au bout ramsès ii reste ramsès le
grand actif plein d'assurance avec une
présence énorme dans la vie de son pays
mais même pour un dieu vivant la faim
dans le monde des mortels est
inéluctable
[Musique]
en 1213 avant jésus-christ ramsès deux
meurt finalement vers l'âge de 90 ans
sachant que l'espérance de vie en égypte
dépasse à peine 30 ans il se peut que
les dieux et voulu ainsi révélé aux
mortels la nature extraordinaire de leur
souverain c'est son troisième fils
mayrand pta qui lui succède régnant
pendant neuf ans avant de mourir à son
tour cependant on ne connaît que deux
des tombes des nombreux autres fils de
ramsès tous les autres ont disparu ce
sont les princes perdu de l'egypte
[Musique]
le long règne de ramsès 2 s'achève en
1212 avant jésus-christ
c'est certainement une période de grande
tristesse en egypte la plupart des
sujets de ramsès ne connaîtront pas
d'autres souverains
quarante jours durant des prêtres se
livre sur le corps de ramsès au rituel
astreignant de la momification l'estomac
les intestins le foie et les poumons
sont placés dans des récipients spéciaux
appelés canopes le corps et déhydraté à
l'aide d'un seul spéciale puis décorez
d'amulettes incrusté de pierreries et
enveloppés dans des bandelettes de l'ain
enfin la momie est placé dans un
cercueil ouvragées et elle commence son
voyage en direction de la vallée des
rois dans le sud de l'egypte nous
trouvons dans le tombeau de ramsès 2
cette magnifique chambre mortuaire n'a
que récemment fait l'objet de fouilles
et n'avait encore jamais été filmées
c'est la plus grande pièce dans la
vallée des rois
le corps momifié du pharaon aura été
transportés dans cette chambre et placé
dans un grand sarcophage situé ici
les canaux contenant ses viscères ont
été posées sur un coffre en albâtre ici
est déposé dans ce puits au dessus se
trouvait une belle chasse en bois ornés
de dorures après avoir terminé leur
dernier rituel les prêtres or ont balayé
les traces poussiéreuses de leurs pas en
sortant à reculant du tombeau laissant
le pharaon sol ici pour l'éternité dans
cet endroit magnifique au sein de la
montagne
[Musique]
le monde a vu les trésors magnifique qui
ont été découverts dans le tombeau du
pharaon toutankhamon mort un peu plus
d'un siècle avant ramsès si c'est là le
trésor qui a été enterré avec
toutankhamon un roi d'importance mineure
qui n'a eu que peu d'influencé sur
l'histoire de l'egypte on ne peut que
tenter d'imaginer les superbes objets et
les décorations qui ont dû remplir le
tombeau de ramsès le grand mais ramsès
n'a pas eu de chance dans le choix de sa
dernière demeure
seulement 150 ans après son enterrement
des pilleurs de tombes ont trouvé le
moyen de pénétrer dans le tombeau du
pharaon des pharaons et ont emporté ce
qui devait être un trésor est
inimaginable
tout ce qui nous reste sont quelques
fragments précieux découvert récemment
par l'égyptologue français christian
leblanc a livré un certain nombre
d'objets qui appartenait à l'équipement
funéraire du roi parmi ces pièces il y a
bien entendu d'abord le sarcophage de
ramsès ii à sarcophage en calcite
albâtre égyptien qui a permis de
regrouper à peu près 450 morceau de ce
type qui nous donne une idée de ce
monument dans lequel avait été placée la
momie de ramsès 2 et puis il y à aussi
et cette pièce absolument exceptionnel
qui représente une statuette de
funéraire de ramsès ii qui appartenait à
cette série de chawki qui était placé
dans la tombe près de la momie du roi
dans une tombe qui devait être
absolument somptueuse et qui devait être
une des plus belle tombe royale de la
nécropole thébaine
les pilleurs se sont attaqués au tombeau
depuis l'origine des enterrements royaux
travaillant généralement en bande
il se doit parfois les gardiens le plus
souvent et s'introduisent simplement
dans les tombeaux par effraction après
que des troubles politiques ou des
menaces à la sécurité nationale ont
distrait l'attention de ce responsable
leur protection
à l'exception de ces quelques objets le
grand trésor funéraire de ramsès a
disparu mais par miracle la momie de
ramsès n'a pas été touché les prêtres
qui considéraient les momies comme des
dieux prennent des mesures drastiques
pour protéger la dépouille de ramsès ii
toute profanation avec le cadavre de son
père c'est ti et de beaucoup d'autres
rois
la momie de ramsès et transporté en
secret vers un ancien tombeau tombé dans
l'oubli depuis longtemps située à à
moins d'un kilomètre et demi de la
vallée des rois
à cet endroit le corps de l'un des plus
grands pharaons d'égypte et déposer sans
cérémonie est entassé avec d'autres
momies royales sa dernière demeure
secrète est si proche et en même temps
si éloigné de l'endroit somptueux
réalisé avec art pour contenir sa
dépouille
son propre tombeau majestueux est
désormais abandonné et sans défense
le dernier outrage a été infligée dans
les siècles suivants l'arrivée de la
momie du pharaon ici par les rares
tempête du désert qui ont alors sévit et
elles ont rempli ce tombeau d'eau
les peintures magnifique et les gravures
qui autrefois couvrez toutes les
surfaces ont été dévastés le plâtre et
tomber des murs les sculptures sur roc
se sont effondrés et les débris
apportées par les inondations ont
progressivement rempli le tombeau
jusqu'au plafond
ceux qui ont découvert cet endroit
pouvait à peine s'y faufiler
[Musique]
finalement plus de 3000 ans après avoir
été caché les momies ont été retrouvés
dans leur cachette en 1881 par le
curateur du musée allemand emil brouch
l'emplacement de la dépouille de ramsès
n'est dès lors plus un secret
cependant on ne trouve rien dans la
cachette des momies ni dans le tombeau
de ramsès qui apporte un éclaircissement
sur le mystère des fils disparu du grand
roi comment ces princes dont l'existence
a été tellement bien documentés ont ils
pu disparaître de l'histoire il faudra
attendre plus d'un siècle pour trouver
une réponse éventuelle cette réponse
suggère que les fils de ramsès se trouve
peut être à quelques minutes de marche
du tombeau de leur père depuis le début
en sortant du tombeau de ramsès vers la
vallée des rois
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya de la compagnie
il ya soixante et un autre tombeau à
quelques minutes de là en montant en
trouve le légendaire tombeau de
toutankhamon
sethi 1er le père de ramsès est enterré
ici mayrand pts à son fils est tout près
mais où sont les tons des nombreux
autres fils de ramsès et bien à une
trentaine de mètres de là se trouve le
tombeau baptisé car v5 et il se peut
plus qu'à 25 détiennent la réponse à
cette question
[Musique]
en 1825 l'égyptologue james burton est
entré dans le tombeau il l'a déclaré
sans importance plus tard tout cet
endroit a été enfoui sous des tonnes de
gravats
les bus de touristes passé à quelques
mètres de là
en 1987 d'égyptologues américain ken
hicks a découvert l'entrée du tombeau
quand enfin il a pu y entrer il a fait
ce que beaucoup considèrent comme la
découverte la plus importante depuis
toutankhamon
pour la première fois en plus de trois
mille ans le monde s'approche enfin tout
doucement de la résolution du grand
mystère des fils disparu de ramsès
[Musique]
pendant quatre cent cinquante ans on
enterre les pharaons d'égypte dans une
gorge déserte pour les mettre à l'abri
des pilleurs de tombes
on a commencé à connaître cette gorge
sous le nom de vallée des rois ici 62
tombeau ont été creusées dans la pierre
calcaire
[Musique]
c'est pas les sauts terrain sont décorés
avec de somptueuses sculptures et
peintures
cependant dès le 3e siècle avant
jésus-christ la vallée des rois est
plongé dans le silence et l'oubli au
début du xviiie siècle un homme de
clergé anglais dénommé richard pocock
visite la vallée et en dessine la
première carte d'autres égyptologue
européens suivront mais leur plan des
tombes ou reste imprécis et leurs
relevés sont inexacts dans les années
1970 le docteur ken au x1 l'égyptologue
américain décide d'entreprendre la
première cartographie de la vallée des
rois en se servant de techniques de
relèvement reposant sur des mesures
extrêmement précises il faudra plus
d'une décennie de travail rien que pour
accumuler toutes les données
malheureusement quand arrivent les
années 1980 il ne reste plus d'argent
pour imprimer la carte détaillée que
weeks voulait alors ils décident
d'utiliser les connaissances qu'il a
accumulés et de s'attaquer à une autre
tâche ambitieuse alors je me suis dit ce
qu'on va faire c'est utiliser le peu
d'argent qui nous restait à ce moment là
pour faire ce que j'avais envisagé de
faire quelques années auparavant il
s'agissait de chercher les archives
historiques d'essayer d'identifier les
tombeaux qui avait été découvert au dix
neuvième siècle mais qui pour une raison
ou pour une autre avait maintenant
disparu et d'essayer de localiser ces
tombeaux et de les placer eux aussi sur
la carte de la vallée des rois
après une recherche approfondie des
archives historiques un tombeau se
détache des autres
ils avaient été inspectés dans le
courant du 19e siècle et on lui avait
attribué l'appellation qu'avait 5 king
vallée number five vallée des rois
numéro cinq en 1825 l'anglais james
burton découpe un tunnel de 25 mètres de
long pour se glisser à l'intérieur du
kavé 5
il réalise un plan à main levée qui
révèlent la présence de onze chambres
cependant ces notes n'aspire ni
enthousiasme ni excitation de la part de
ses confrères
[Musique]
même au world carter qui a découvert la
tombe de toutankhamon ne se sert du
flanc de la colline qui avait cinq que
comme dépotoir pour y verser les débris
provenant de ces fouilles
ils ont en fruits le tombeau sous trois
mètres de débris
et comme si cela ne suffisait pas une
autre série de crues subites causées par
les pluies torrentielles qui s'abattent
de temps à autre sur la vallée des rois
ont déversé davantage de débris sur
l'entrée du tombeau la dissimulant
complètement en 1920 et sans doute même
avance la cave et 5 n'était plus qu'un
vague souvenir lointain il n'y avait
rien à voir néanmoins quel os x est
intrigué par les croquis du tombeau
réalisé par burton sur son plan il ne
ressemblait à aucun des autres tombeau
que j'avais vu jusqu alors la plupart
des tombes de la vallée des rois sont
fait de longs couloirs creuser
profondément dans le soubassement en
revanche d'après le croquis de burton ce
tombeau possédait six chambres qui
partait dans toutes les directions
depuis l'entrée comme les tentacules
d'une pieuvre et j'ai pensé quelle
étrange tombeau et si on essayait de le
localiser
l'attention de weeks est attiré par
autre chose
en 1989 des chercheurs suggèrent que le
kavé 5 perdus et peut être aussi le
tombeau manquant contenant les
dépouilles des enfants de ramsès d'après
les notes de burton kendrick ça une idée
de l'endroit dans la vallée où commencer
ses recherches il prend une décision il
va essayer de retrouver ce qui est perdu
depuis si longtemps
nous avons creusé une tranchée droite
d'environ un mètre de large
la première chose que nous avons trouvée
était une entaille dans le soubassement
qui était très nettement délimiter une
entaille fait par l'homme
non pas une dépression ou un puits
naturels dans le flanc de la colline et
ensuite nous avons trouvé des traces
indiquant la présence d'escalier après
des mois de travail acharné
l'équipe de ken hicks a déblayé le puits
d'entrée du kavé 5 le moment de
découvrir l'intérieur est enfin arrivé
ce durant l'été 1989 nous avions dégagé
l'escalier atteint cette ouverture
maintenant la première chambre
ça ne ressemblait pas du tout à cela
c'était complètement rempli du sol au
plafond des débris que les inondations
avaient déposé là à quel niveau à peu
près jusqu'ici et c'est uniquement grâce
aux tout-petits canal creusé par james
burton en 1825 que l'on pouvait voir
quoi que ce soit à l'intérieur
ici on voit des traces noire causée par
la lampe de burton sur les plafonds là
où ils étaient en train de regarder
alors vous vous êtes faufiler dans la
petite ouverture que burton avait créé
c'est exact ça c'était le seul accès
pour entrer dans le tombeau et même à ce
stade là on ne pouvait pas voir les murs
sur les côtés est ce que nous sommes en
train de parler deux centimètres ici de
quel genre de dimension s'agissait-il
eh bien disons que c'était un peu étroit
pour moi on peut dire ça très étroit
alors vous avez réussi à vous glisser à
l'intérieur ne vous du temps sans doute
pas que vous ayez travaillé dans cette
pièce et pour combien de temps il nous a
fallu cinq ans pour nettoyer cette
chambre
mais dès la deuxième année nous savions
que nous étions sur une piste
intéressante dans qu'avait 5
parce que dans la partie haute des murs
nous avions trouvé toute une série de
hiéroglyphes indiquant que ce tombeau
était le lieu de sépulture de l'un des
fils de ramsès 2 dont la cartouche se
trouve ici et nous avons son nom à mon
père qui pêchait
il faut savoir que c'était le premier
fils de ramsès 2 c'était donc la
première confirmation que l'un des fils
de ramsès était peut-être enterrés ici
oui exactement et le fils aîné en plus
de ça mais peu après il est arrivé
quelque chose d'encore mieux parce que
sur ce mur quand nous avons exposé le
texte pour la partie supérieure nous
avons trouvé une autre scène avec ramsès
un dieu et un fils qui s'il n'est pas à
moins épais chef se fit cela nous
l'appelons ramsès juniors afin d'éviter
toute confusion avec son père tout à
coup nous étions sûrs que ce tombeau
contenait plusieurs sépultures à ce
stade au moins deux des fils du
souverain était enterré dans le tombeau
c'était quelque chose que l'on n'avait
jamais vu auparavant kendrick est
désormais certain que qu'avait 5 promet
d'être bien plus qu'un simple tombeau
bien qu'il ne sache pas encore si les
plus grands coller aux chambres
détaillées sur le croquis originale de
burton
mais le progrès dans la découverte des
secrets de cave et 5 est effroyablement
lent
[Musique]
la vallée des rois reçoit en moyenne un
ou deux millimètres de plus par an au
maximum
cependant de temps à autres peut-être
tous les 50 60 70 ans
une pluie torrentielle s'abat à cet
endroit et cause un désastre quand les
inondations et les débris athènes
qu'avait 5
l'entrée de la vallée elles peuvent se
déplacer à 45 65 kilomètres à l'heure
transportant des grosses pierres de la
taille de cuisinière et de
réfrigérateurs les onze innovation qui
touche qui avait 5 le remplisse
complètement de débris sable vase et des
morceaux de calcaire qui au cours des
siècles s'assèche atteignant une
consistance proche du ciment enlevaient
des tonnes de débris a porté par les
inondations qui remplissent le tombeau
s'avère prendre énormément de temps les
techniques pour retirer la terre du
tombeau ou de n'importe quels sites
archéologiques en egypte n'ont pas
beaucoup changé dans les cent dernières
années
nous utilisons toujours des paniers ceux
ci sont fait de vieux pneus nous les
remplissons à l'aide de truelle de
pelles de pioches peu importe qu'elle
ait portons à la main en faisant la
chaîne jusqu'à l'entrée du tombeau il
faut cinq ans rien que pour vider deux
petites salles
[Musique]
bien qu'il ait découvert les noms de
deux des fils de ramsès kent weeks n'a
rien trouvé d'autre maintenant la
chambre numéro trois un peu plus grande
attend d'être nettoyé ce que weeks va
découvrir dans cette partie du tombeau
va récompenser toutes les années de
patience et de travail acharné kendricks
à ramper dans cette troisième chambre à
travers la petite brèche que vous voyez
il espérait trouver quelque chose sous
cet énorme tas de débris
il n'arrivait pas à l'atteindre il a
réalisé que la fragilité de ses piliers
et ces fissures menaçante dans le
plafond en pierre calcaire au dessus de
la tête devaient être stabilisées
ce travail vient juste d'être terminée
la carte de burton montre une porte
mystérieuse sur le mur du fond vers
laquelle kendricks s'approche
progressivement en creusant jusqu'en
1995 quand il a réussi à trouver
suffisamment de place pour se glisser
dans cette ouverture ce qui s'est passé
après et l'un des plus grands moments de
l'archéologie moderne
kenzo x se prépare enfin à explorer au
delà de la troisième chambre
il va entrer dans un espace dans lequel
personne n'a pénétré depuis des pharaons
[Musique]
nous pensions que nous pouvions trouver
une autre petite chambre comme celle à
l'avant chambres 1 chambre de au lieu de
ça nous avons pointé nos lampes
électriques et nous ne voyons rien le
noir complet ça signifie que la chambre
continue encore et encore nous ne
pouvions pas voir de mur au fond plus
tard nous avons installé l'électricité
dans le tombeau
nous avons découvert le spectacle plus
incroyable que j'avais jamais vu
après presque 30 mètres dans le couloir
qui était flanqué de portes de chaque
côté nous aurions trouvé une statue du
dieu osiris
donc vous avez fait des progrès ici vous
deviez déjà savoir que c'était la
découverte la plus remarquable
je n'arrêtais pas de me dire mon dieu je
n'arrive pas y croire il n'ya rien de
tel ailleurs dans la vallée des rois
il y à des chambres ici de chaque côté
environ tous les trois mètres nous
trouvions une ouverture conduisant à de
petites chambres ou à des suites de
salle la plupart sont obstruées vous
pouvez voir à l'intérieur mais nous ne
savons pas encore dégagé vous deviez
savoir à cet instant que ce que vous
étiez en train de découvrir était sans
doute l'une des plus importantes
découvertes archéologiques du siècle
rien de tel n'a encore jamais été
découvert auparavant alors vous êtes
arrivé ici et vous avez eu cette vision
fantastique
une statue grandeur nature de ce que
nous pensions d'abord être le dieu
osiris et que nous pensons maintenant
être une représentation du roi ramsès en
osiris leroy divino et accueillant ses
fils dans le couloir dans la vie future
la superbe statue de ramsès apporte une
preuve supplémentaire indiquant avec
quasi certitude qu'il s'agit du tombeau
de ses fils royaux de plus avec la
découverte du couloir 7 et de son
complexe de salles le monde commence à
entrevoir la signification de ce que
weeks a révélé
[Musique]
la plupart des tombeaux de la vallée des
rois ne contiennent pas plus de huit
pièces celui de ramsès premier le
grand-père de ramsès legrand en comporte
seulement 4 tout comme celui du
légendaire toutankhamon weeks a déjà
découvert 65 salles et d'autres sont
rapidement mises en évidence on n'avait
jamais rien trouvé de tel qu avait 5
semble partir dans toutes les directions
à la fois ce couloir me laisse perplexe
il descend plus abruptement que
n'importe quel autre couloir dans le
tombeau en fait certaines des chambres
latéral qui se découpent ici se situe en
réalité sur le sol des chambres du
niveau supérieur
[Musique]
au pied de ce couloir en pente raide
tout à coup on descend quatre marches et
on se trouve dans un autre grand hall
avec des piliers
ici on a trois piliers au centre de
cette salle rectangulaire il s'agit
d'ailleurs d'un bon exemple de la
stratigraphie à laquelle on fait face
dans qu'avait 5
cette chambre est remplie comme l'autre
jusqu'au plafond de débris déposée par
les inondations vous pouvez voir les
différentes couches
[Musique]
tout au fond du tombeau les débris des
inondations continuent de poser problème
voici l'un des nombreux couloirs de cave
est simple qui n'ont pas fait l'objet de
fouilles
celui-ci se dirige vers le sud
directement vers le tombeau de
toutankhamon et personne ne sait
pourquoi il y à un mur aveugle à la fin
à la peut-être une ouverture le problème
est d'arriver à l'atteindre avec toutes
ses chambres ses couloirs ce tombeau
fait presque la taille de la moitié d'un
terrain de football et il est
entièrement rempli de ces débris
derrière ce mur ils trouveront peut-être
d'autres vestiges de poterie de cannes
ap peut être même des cadavres momifié
certains de ces débris sont aussi dur
que du béton une excavation mécanique
est hors de question c'est à dire des
tonnes et des tonnes de débris doit être
dégagés à la main
mais les débris des inondations ne sont
que l'un des obstacles qui dissimule
encore les secrets de cave et 5
je pense que c'est potentiellement l'une
des parties les plus intéressantes de
cave et 5
malheureusement c'est aussi la plus
dangereuse parce qu'elle est située sous
la route qui est empruntée par les bus
de tourisme depuis 40 ans son plafond
s'est effondré serait un projet
extrêmement onéreux je suis prêt à vous
pariez que si l'on était capable de le
faire
on trouverait la preuve ici peut-être
sous la forme d'un sarcophage peut être
un autre élément de matériel funéraire
démontrant clairement que cette chambre
5 et l'endroit où l'un des fils du roi
et intérêts à cause des inondations des
sculptures et peintures sur les murs de
cave et cinq ont été sévèrement
endommagés
cependant alors qu'on commence à vider
les chambres des vestiges de sculptures
indique de façon manifeste que cav et
cinq étaient autrefois magnifiquement
décoré la sculpture de ce mur noir ici
dans le couloir 7 c'est absolument
spectaculaire c'est l'un des meilleurs
exemples de sculptures en relief que
l'on est dans le ton boulot bien sûr à
l'origine ils étaient peints et tout ce
qui nous reste maintenant sont les
contours
malgré cela vous pouvez voir l'exécution
soigner dans cette silhouette d'un fils
dont le nom a malheureusement disparu
cette fois encore offert en cadeau par
son père ramsès ii au milieu d'un tas
d'offrandes pour les dieux en
l'occurrence can you et la ds à tort
dont le beau visage et élégamment
sculpté cependant une chose étrange se
produit dans ce couloir à cet endroit
précis jusque là nous avions deux bouts
relief sculpté cela s'arrête
et au lieu de ça à partir d'ici les murs
deviennent rugueux huit ont été comme on
dit préparé pour le plâtre âge je n'ai
pas la moindre idée sur la raison
expliquant cela et que c'était une
possibilité
peut-être qu'à l'origine le couloir
s'arrêter à cet endroit elle n'est pas
plus loin et ensuite de couloir a été
prolongée le tombeau a été agrandi afin
de fournir des sépultures supplémentaire
pour les autres fils de ramsès ii qui
l'avait précédé à la mort
alors que toujours plus de sculptures
endommagés sont découvertes dans le
tombeau
le travail consistant à leur restituer
leur forme originelle a été assurée par
suzanne les pousses de kent
elle a laborieusement effectuer des
calques h détaillé qui sont étudiées
afin de recréer les sculptures
manquantes et les peintures qui les
ornais
une fois que les lignes manquantes sont
redessinées suzanne reproduit les
couleurs originales à partir de
minuscules fragments de pigments
retrouver sur les murs du tombeau et il
s'agit d'un fils de ramsès
il porte un vêtement sacerdotale sacré
assez sophistiqué jaune avec des rayures
rouges
chaque jour est excitant on ne sait
jamais ce que l'on va peut-être voir
chaque fois que l'on regarde les murs
j'ai beau avoir peut-être déjà dessiné
le mur est fixée le mur pendant dix
jours
de temps à autre la lumière change il y
a quelque chose de différent que je vois
pour la première fois
nous pouvons enfin après trois mille
cinq cents ans à nouveau admirer les
peintures qui autrefois mettait ce
tombeau en valeur
cependant dans qu'avait 5 le succès est
souvent suivie de frustration le tombeau
semble se jouer des weeks comme si le
grand ramsès lui-même s'efforçait de
dissimuler la clé du mystère de ses fils
disparu nous savons qu'à l'origine ce
tombeau était magnifiquement décorée
avec des bas-reliefs peints de couleurs
brillantes mais à cause des inondations
une grande partie de la peinture et du
plâtre ont été emportées par les eaux et
c'est d'autant plus frustrant dans cette
scène dans la seconde chambre
si nous avons ramsès 2 une silhouette de
son fils est juste au dessus du fils
nous pouvons seulement discerner des
hiéroglyphes le fils du roi de son corps
et le nom a disparu
nous n'avons pas la moindre idée de qui
il peut s'agir étant donné le titre sa
silhouette du fils nous étions très
excités par ce cas il peut s'agir du
fisc numéro 6 numéros 7 ou numéro 8 sur
notre liste déjà enterré dans ce tombeau
nous étions si près du but mais l'avons
ratée de peu après dix années de
fouilles qu'avait 5 avec plus de 100
chambres s'est avéré être le temps pour
le plus grand à la conception unique de
la vallée des rois et sans doute de
toute l'egypte il est évident qu'il a
été construit par ramsès ii et petit à
petit on commence à accumuler les
éléments de preuve indiquant qu'il a
effectivement créé ce tombeau pour ses
nombreux fils
[Musique]
nous avons les noms de plusieurs défis
s'inscrit sur les murs de kaveh 5 nous
avons plus de deux douzaines de
représentation du roi faisant offrant de
plusieurs de ses fils au dieu dans
l'après vie nous avons des objets
funéraires des canaux qui ont été
découverts dans plusieurs chambres de
calais 5
il comporte les noms et titre de 5 des
fils de ramsès ii kendrick se trouve
bientôt des preuves de nature beaucoup
plus personnelle en 1998 qu'avaient 5 a
commencé à restituer quelques uns des
corps qui reposaient dans cette tombe
particulière depuis si longtemps
[Musique]
comme dans tout bon mystère ce qu'il
faut pour résoudre qu'avec 5 est un
corps après neuf ans de recherche
kenshoo x en a finalement trouvé un
nous menions tellement de projets de
front durant les premières années de
travail sûres qu'ils avaient 5 que nous
n'avons dégager la moitié nord de cette
salle que deux saisons plus tôt et à
notre grande surprise lorsque nous avons
atteint le niveau du sol
nous avons trouvé deux entailles
parallèle très bien faite qui délimitait
ce qui était à l'évidence un puits je
pense qu'à l'origine
ceci était peut-être le lieu de
sépulture de quiconque était enterré là
quand ce n'était encore qu'un ton bois
de chambre au cours de la xviiie
dynastie ce que nous avons trouvé en
arrivant au fond du puits était une
série de couches d'ossements et en
dessous trois crânes d'hommes adultes
avec la vertèbre du cou encore attachés
ainsi que des traces de tissus et de
bandelettes momifié sur leurs cadavres
en dessous de ça nous avons découvert le
corps encore entièrement articulé d'un
jeune homme adulte une momie d'environ
50 ans ou chez dans cette position
directement sur le sol et je pense que
d'après la position des bras et celle du
corps il est probable que ce corps et
peut être aussi les trois autres crânes
et appartenu au fils de ramsès 2
pourquoi une momie d'une telle
importance
aurait-elle été abandonnée dans un pays
aussi rudimentaire et sans ornement
kendricks pense que la réponse est très
simple lorsque les pilleurs de tombes
ont pénétré dans qu'avait 5
ils sont descendus profondément dans le
tombeau à l'intérieur des chambres
funéraires de ses fils pour attraper les
momies et les ont remontés ici près de
la porte d'entrée là où la lumière était
meilleure et où ils pouvaient voir ce
qu'il faisait
ils ont mis les corps en pièces à la
recherche de bijoux en or et de colliers
pectoraux et ainsi de suite et ensuite
ils ont simplement ajouté les morceaux
de cadavres par terre certains d'entre
eux ont été entraînés dans ce puits par
les eaux ceci est l'un des trois crânes
provenant du puits à l'intérieur de la
chambre numéro deux et nous sommes
maintenant en train de le nettoyer
nous le préparons pour qu'il soit étudié
non pas par nous mais pas rappelé
anatomiste et des généticiens
toutes les dents sont assez fortement
usées y compris celles de devant les
incisives et les canines et toutes ces
caractéristiques prises avec les futurs
les jointures entre les os du crâne
suggère qu'il s'agit sans doute d'un
sujet adultes de sexe masculin
bien entendu ce que nous voulons
maintenant c'est essayer de déterminer
si nous pouvons y arriver si ce crâne
appartenait à un individu qui était
apparenté aux autres cadavres dans le
tombeau
nous aimerions vraiment beaucoup leur
trouver un lien de parenté avec ramsès
tous ceux qui ont vu une photographie de
la momie de ramsès ou même en fait une
représentation de ramsès dans l'art
égyptien reconnaissent le fait qu'il est
représenté avec un est très pro éminents
et cela pourrait être l'une des
caractéristiques anatomiques que nous
rechercherons lyon afin d'essayer de
déterminer des relations
l'analyse scientifique du crâne n'est
que l'une des nombreuses tâches qui ne
peuvent être accomplies dans la
poussière et sous la chaleur de la
vallée des rois
certains des travaux les plus exigeants
dans la découverte des secrets de cars
et 5 ne s'effectue pas du tout ici dans
le tombeau mais plutôt dans un bureau au
caire
[Musique]
quand nous avons commencé le travail sur
le projet de cartographie de thèbes en
1979 nous ne disposions que d'un budget
un film
aujourd'hui nous avons du personnel à
temps complet huit employés sur ce
projet du personnel composé de
volontaires à temps partiel et
d'employés à temps partiel qui sont
éparpillés à travers le monde
c'est un projet très diversifié et ce
qui est amusant pour un archéologue de
nos jours c'est en fait d'essayer de
réunir toutes ces spécialités disparates
pourriez vous remontez cette section que
j'aimerais faire
sommer s'est jeté un coup d'oeil à ce
détail le travail de nos graphistes et
de nos architectes est extrêmement utile
il nous offre un nouveau moyen
d'examiner regarder les matériaux et
effectué des études comparatives de ces
matériaux nous voulons réaliser un cd
rom sur la nécropole de thèbes en nous
servant des photographies que nos
employés ont rassemblé dessin
architecturaux que nous avons préparée
et bien sûr des matériaux historique
également on pourra par exemple
s'arrêter sur un site tel que le temple
de louxor sur la rive est et on pourra
générer toute une série de dessins en
trois dimensions montrant les
différentes étapes dans la construction
de ce temple aussi bien sûr qu'avec 5
nous pensions pouvoir produire quelque
chose qui soit non seulement utiles aux
chercheurs mais qu'ils puissent être
également amusant et excitant pour les
écoliers par exemple des enfants de 8 9
ans qui étudie l'égyptologie à l'école
pour la première fois en dépit de tous
ses efforts kendricks est le premier à
admettre qu'il ya encore beaucoup à
faire dans qu'avait 5
le travail est lent et astreignant et la
tâche n'arrête pas d'augmenter jusqu'à
présent 150 salles ont été découvertes
et seulement 7 % d'entre elles ont été
dégagés
cependant une chose est maintenant sûr
en trois mille ans de construction de
tombeau dans l'egypte ancienne
il n'existe rien qui ressemble même
vaguement ac avait 5
que ce soit par sa taille ou par son
incroyable conception
[Musique]
pourquoi ramsès ii at-il apparemment
créer un mausolée si inhabituelle pour
ses nombreux fils kendricks pense avoir
trouvé une réponse
[Rires]
nous savons que durant son règne il
s'est lui même déclaré divin il devait
transférer à ses enfants ou tout au
moins à l'héritier présomptif nombreux
des devoirs c'est cuillé qu'il aurait
habituellement exécutées
dès lors que l'un de ses fils l'héritier
présomptif était sacré pharaons séculier
il était plus simplement un fils qui
devrait un jour hériter du trône
il était un sou roi il faut enterrer un
sou roi de manière un peu plus élaboré
nombre de ses autres fils qui chacun à
leur tour avait occupé cette étrange
place de son roi sont morts avant lui et
ils ont été enterrés dans ce très
curieux tombeau
il y à toujours plus de questions que de
réponses qui reste à découvrir dans le
kavé 5
cependant le tombeau a démontré que nos
connaissances sur l'égypte ancienne sont
loin d'être exhaustive
comme toujours pour kendricks la
recherche continue il voulait devenir
égyptologue depuis son enfance dans
l'état de washington
il espère maintenant pouvoir apporter sa
contribution à la profession qu'il aime
tellement
au cours des prochaines années
en plus de notre travail dans qu'avait 5
l'une des choses que j'aimerais le plus
faire et aider au développement d'un
plan directeur pour la protection de la
vallée des rois est en fait pour tout eh
ben la nappe phréatique remontant la
pollution l'augmentation de la
population dans les villages voisins
l'augmentation du tourisme sont en train
d'ébranler tous les sites ici et
tombeaux les temps il n'y a rien qui
pourrait me rendre aussi triste que de
réaliser que les générations à venir
pourraient se voir privé de
l'opportunité de visiter un endroit
aussi magique que la vallée des rois
il serait vraiment dommage que d'ici un
siècle d enfant de 8 ans à everett
washington ne puisse pas rêver d'un
endroit comme celui-ci comme je l'avais
fait moi même
[Musique]
kendrick ce travail sur cave et 5 depuis
plus de dix ans parfois il n'y avait
aucune garantie que son travail aille
révéler davantage que quelques salles
vides
avec toujours la distraction d'avoir à
trouver des fonds pour financer tout
ceci dans sa patience et un travail
acharné ont donné naissance à ce qui est
en train de devenir l'une des plus
exaltantes découverte en egypte au cours
des années qui viennent car les 5 va
révéler davantage de ses secrets dans
quel bulls cette immense tombeau at il
été bâti qui était la venue de son
contenu est peut-être peut-être
seulement kendricks découvrira-t-il
c'est d'autre des fils du grand ramsès
repose encore quelque part dans ses murs
[Musique]
dans le prochain épisode d'égypte au
delà des pyramides
il y à de nombreux signes de vie
sexuelle avant le mariage
comment les égyptiens de l'époque vivait
et mouret pourquoi ont-ils été abattus
ici c'est sinistre
les solutions habituelles de guerre
famille maladie
découvrez les étonnantes révélations de
la terre d'égypte dans le prochain
épisode d'égypte au delà des pyramides
[Musique]